former England Captain Michael Vaughn
arriving to fight charges of racism
the only person accused to attend public
disciplinary hearings into a scandal
that's rocked English cricket
as in rafik is Seeking Justice from the
commission two and a half years after
going public the victim of racial
harassment and bullying across two
spells playing for Yorkshire between
2008 and 2018. day two of the hearings
focused on Vaughn and an incident before
a match with Yorkshire in 2009 it's
alleged this is when Vaughn directed the
comment there's too many of you lot at
Rafiq and three other Yorkshire
teammates with Asian backgrounds
was challenged by Michael Vaughn's
lawyer over why it took him 11 years to
raise the accusation of racism rafit
responded that he waited until he had
enough courage to raise an instant that
caused him upset and anger and he said
that he's still carrying the mental
scars
the hearing is yet to hear from Vaughn
whose lawyer Christopher Stoner Casey
said Mr Vaughn cannot recall precisely
what he said but it's clear the words
used and in the context used are
unacceptable Mr Vaughn is adamant he did
not use them
another former teammate adio Rashid
claims he did
but giving evidence from Bangladesh
where he's playing for England Rasheed
said he was not offended and the alleged
comments seemed bad humor
Vaughn is expected to give evidence on
Friday the ashes winning Captain denies
wrongdoing in a case that threatens his
reputation and future work around
cricket
Rob Harris Sky News Central London